look fair warning a big chunk of this
review is gonna be me comparing this to
the original even though I'm sure some
people will tell me I just need to Letty
[Applause]
[Music]
cold never bothered me anyway all right
before we get into this this one is
sponsored by me and my own merch
because you may have noticed I'm still
getting I'm still getting the full
rollout going with pot we're looking
into updating titles or whatever but
I've got a new logo and that means I've
got new merch to slap that logo on too
if you go to teespring
you can get a discount if you order
between now and the end of Black Friday
coupon codes down in the description
check them out use them where my merch
you'll be cool maybe I don't know you'll
laut yourself as a geek at the very
least yes so anyway frozen - I have seen
it took my kid to it and okay it brought
to mind similar issues that I had would
say Ralph breaks the Internet
and to some extent Incredibles -
although I think to a lesser extent in
both cases I like this better than I
think I liked either of those but it
really does pale in comparison to the
original in a lot of key areas or at
least what were key areas for me and why
I really liked the original frozen now
depending on what it is you like about
that first movie your mileage may vary
and there are absolutely some very
strong points of this film
the first thing because this kind of
matters my kid liked it a lot in fact at
least at the time of coming out of it
she says she thinks she likes him more
than the original now I can tell you
from experience she can be
prisoner of the moment a little bit and
kind of the last thing she saw it tends
to be her favorite thing at least for a
little bit but she definitely had a good
time
she had no issues no complaints so when
I start getting into that end of things
which is also going to involve spoilers
but I will give you warning before I go
there when I start getting into that
thing it's very much going to be an
adult's perspective of the things an
adult liked about the previous one so if
you want to know if your kid will like
it yes your kid will probably like it
and as far as what there is that is good
about it well first of all look it's
gorgeous this is a beautiful looking
film they came up with some really great
stunning just amazing visual elements I
mean the previous one was good looking
films as well but the Hobbit was some
really good visual set pieces here
incorporating you know the some things
that you've seen in the trailer with the
ocean the ice and things like that
there's some amazing things done with
fire that are really cool with this and
just overall the design the feel the set
piece is really just gorgeous stunningly
beautiful film all the performances are
solid the singing is good although the
songs I don't think there is good
they're pretty good um they there's a
song very clearly being positioned to be
this films let it go and that one's
called into the unknown and that was
pretty good I'm a little bit annoyed
that that ones getting the big push
because a later song called show
yourself is actually a lot stronger at
least in my opinion but son other than
that the songs are well sung not always
as purposeful I mean there were a couple
of superfluous ish songs in the first
one but I felt that more strongly about
more of the songs in this in terms of
what the song was doing obviously it's a
musical you don't have to have
characters persons a song so they're all
superfluous in a way but in terms of
feeling like this was the point to have
a song and this is the thing a song in
this story should be about
not everything quite clicked there but
again performances are really solid I
was surprised how funny
Olaf remains that God the kids in the
audience especially losing their minds
at how much they laughed at Olaf but
even as an adult I really kind of
expected his stick to a worn off on me
by now no it was pretty it was still
pretty funny I don't know what it is
about that about that snowman I'm
actually not a huge fan of Josh GAD but
this works not gonna lie and yeah anyone
who isn't going to look at the deeper
level of this thing and that's not me
saying like if you like it you're not
looking at it deeply but I'm saying if
what you liked about the original was
surface-level if what you liked was the
songs the images the jokes things like
that if those are your top reasons for
liking the original frozen regardless of
what your age is you're gonna have a
good time with this however if you're
like me and you feel that the strongest
thing that the original frozen had going
for it was narrative cohesion that's not
so much the case here yeah I try to
think if there's a way for me to explain
that without getting into spoilers well
there isn't there isn't I can lead into
it spoiler free but I'm gonna have to
get indisposed to get into explicit
examples so let me explain what I mean
about in the first film the first film
hat was incredibly strong thematically
now when I say that that doesn't mean
that like everything fed into a single
theme there were multiple themes going
on but they were themes that
complemented each other and they fit
together so you had also with a whole
with number of things going on with her
in terms of repression of self and how
the damage that can cause around you
when inevitably it all kind of blows up
her coming to believe that she can be
accepted in the world with people who
love her because she doesn't believe she
can and that is very much complemented
by Ana's themes which have to do with
come she has to come to terms with the
fact that the world
not going to be this magical fairytale
where everything's perfect and ideal and
she has learning to do else as learning
to do the themes of their journeys knit
together very well and pretty much every
other character factors into that in
some way
Hans factors in as being the harshest
lesson that Anna could have learned in
terms of what the problem with her world
outlook is as far as Elsa go she has
something very similar in that original
one because her pushing people away
almost gets hurt sister actually
honestly does get her sister killed but
then it is the mending of that rift and
the familial love between them that
saves her and brings her back even
someone like Olaf has thematic relevance
because his naivete is basically Ana's
taken to an extreme when she's kind of
threatened she has it shoved in her face
like oh yeah okay there's the level of
naivety that is a problem
and things just all fit together and
complement each other and build on each
other and even things that seem like
more superfluous likes a bit of a
fixer-upper actually while not the
strongest song and the thing it has
thematic relevance because part of Ana's
journey is to realize that people are
fixer-uppers it's not all perfect as is
because she went out thinking I'll just
meet the perfect guy and everything
you'll be wonderful like no that's not
reality you're not gonna find that but
that doesn't mean that you don't have
something that you can work with so
everything had the Matic relevance to
themes that were complementary to each
other the theming in frozen 2 is
honestly first of all it's a lot harder
to pin down in the first place I'm not
gonna call it devoid of themes they are
there but they don't build on each other
and the various elements of the film
including the songs and especially
including the magical elements don't
compliment and strengthen the themes in
the way that they did in the original in
fact in some cases they feel like they
undercut them in a way that is quite
where your honor the very least they
muddle and confuse them there are things
about the way that the mad
and the fantastical elements in this
work that if it is intended to relate to
the themes that I'm seeing I can't
figure out how
which means I'm either miss reading the
themes or there's something else going
on that I'm missing or they just
flat-out don't connect and honestly some
of what's going on here is things that
are fairly common if you try and do a
sequel to a film with a very strong
thematic core which is in that previous
film things that were there were there
because they built up the themes where
when you come to the sequel things are
there because well it was in the
previous film so we got to bring it back
even though their role in it doesn't
complement the overall thing
unfortunately Kristoff is a really good
example of that his whole thing going on
with him is incredibly disconnected from
everything else going on and his song
that he gets called lost in the woods
which is a decent song in and of itself
was really jarring I'm sitting there
thinking like this like this is your
issue dude like really time and place
man come on
and yeah not it didn't didn't work I do
need to start getting spoilers because I
need to start talking specific so from
here on out there be spoilers ye be
warned I don't know why it just became a
pirate there but we're rolling with it
okay so I brought up the magic and I'm
gonna complain a bit about the magic and
I want people to understand that my
complaints about the magic are thematic
not logistical the original film the
logic didn't totally flow in terms of
what the rules of this magic is and how
it works and what the limitations of it
are because as far as Elsa's powers you
know she just makes cold and creates ice
but then she can like also control it
and build a castle and like create life
with marshmallow and all of like that it
doesn't make total logical sense but it
makes the mattock sense in in pretty
much every case especially when you
consider that Olaf like you said is a
bit of an exaggeration of Anna and
marshmallow is basically an exaggeration
of Elsa her and her desire to be alone
to push everyone away and Elsa's
you know desire to just get everyone
together and have warm hugs so
everything fits the matically even if
you could poke logistical holes into it
this time
the logistical holes I'm not sure are
that much worse than they were in the
first film but because they don't have
the thematic backing they bother me here
in a way they didn't bother me in the
original and part of that is that they
add a heck of a lot more magic because
Elsa was really the only magical element
in play in the first one they kind of
got away with playing fast and loose but
they more magical elements you involve
in something the more you kind of need
to parse out wait how does this work
again and they kind of don't and
normally I don't really need an
explanation but the lack of explanation
or the tiny scant bits we get again
muddles the theming especially when
there are implications of the desires of
nature and this nebulous idea of spirits
and basically there's a motivation the
magical forces of the world have a
motive and they want a thing which kind
of means you need to tie it all together
nor explain a little bit better once
something starts acting with motive it
can no longer be just a thing that
happens it's a it's effectively a
character now and so that I don't feel
that really got done and so some little
logistical stuff that I I don't think
would have bothered me so much if I felt
the theming was stronger or things like
okay so and like I said spoilers Elsa
gets this call she hears this song that
no one else hears well we find out that
that is kind of her mother but it's kind
of just the memory of her mother which
first of all once we get the explanation
of that why can't on I hear it because
Elsa doesn't have any particularly
stronger connection to her mother than
Anna would have so we don't know that
why is Elsa only hearing this now what
triggered it for her to hear it now as
opposed to at any other point previously
why didn't she hear it when she was all
by herself with zero distractions up in
her ice palace in that stretch of the
previous film again I'm not sure it
actually matters for an answer but these
things are jumping out at me because I'm
not flowing with the overall thing I
think it also helps that the previous
film had a very clear issue to deal with
you know Kingdom frozen unfasten thought
Kingdom how do we do that go deal with
Elsa cool problem clear path for how we
at least think we're going to deal with
this this one Elsa feels a pull to some
place okay
and there are apparently now spirits
release which she did by accident but
maybe it's bad maybe it's not okay
shoulder and something about her pass
and her parents but okay like that
there's no clear mission to what they're
doing and by the time they get what it's
very late in the game and on and so like
here's what I mean about week thumb
attic elements when Elsa gets to the I
forget what they call it but she gets to
the place at the end and I know they'd
set up the whole thing about you go too
deep you drown or whatever but
thematically what is this saying if you
undo your own past history it kills you
except that her finding that stuff out
which first of all is kind of a kind of
a weak reveal because it's a reveal and
a twist about somebody that neither
honor nor Elsa ever actually knew in
real life anyways but like that
knowledge also empowered Anna to do the
thing that needed to happen that was the
good thing but it was bad cuz Elsa died
and articles at a sacrifice except it's
not cuz Elsa wasn't planning to die to
find that out she just did it and that
happened to kill her temporarily of
course um which also and it also annoys
me that we get to fake out death and
revivals one fine we had one last time
but to do with both her and Olaf it's a
little cheap but like the matically
that's that's a mess
what is that saying and I don't hold
that standard to any film but when
you're following up on a film where
there are thematic answers to basically
any question where you ask wait why is
it this way because maybe the logistics
don't make total sense there's a
thematic answer that you can give this
one there isn't for a lot of these
things at least not that I can find and
also talking about weakening stuff so
honest big decision in her big moment
and like look let me be clear I really
like the sentiment of do the next good
thing the next best thing whatever it is
it's like if you don't know where you're
going long term just look at the short
term what is the best thing that I can
do right now so do that I actually
really like that as a message but again
it's a message of like a song and like
one other thing it is it doesn't it
doesn't get built as a major through
line for Anna as a character the way her
development of the first one did so
again comparatively just annoys me
anyway he's God huh okay maybe this
thing did irritate me a little bit more
than I let on at the beginning but
anyways let me get there so Otto makes
this whole revelation that they need to
break the dam because the dam was not
built to bring two kingdoms together it
was built in order to weaken one Kingdom
so that her that her Kingdom arendelle
could basically control them and she
realizes we have to break this dam but
she already knows breaking the dam will
flood arendelle now her decision to do
that is difficult for her but is
relieved by she knows the towns already
the kingdom the city has already been
evacuated there are no human beings
there they will lose the their homes but
that can be rebuilt the people are safe
and yet Anna comes - I'm sorry Elsa
comes to comes gets revived and stops it
and the Kingdom saved but there's no
tension in that because there were no
people left there and it undermines ah
the decision that Anna made because she
made the hard choice I'm going to cause
destruction
in the interest of something more
important but then the destruction
doesn't happen a sacrifice isn't worth
much if in the end you actually didn't
have to sacrifice anything again really
really really weak
the matically and just it was just
frustrating and again not because it's
bad in and of itself taking us a film
unto itself it's fine but I'm gonna hold
it to a higher standard on these layers
on these depths on the thematic elements
because that for me was what made the
first film truly great I did like the
more superficial stuff I did like the
characters and the and you know the
performances of them and the songs and
the visuals and it was funny when it
wanted to be I enjoyed all that but why
I truly loved the first one was the
thematic depth to it and that is not
here it's not an absent of themes but it
is an absence of of them being anywhere
nearly as well structured as
complementary and as cohesive as they
were in the first film and if you're
gonna do a sequel to previous film that
that that was as the matically tight as
frozen was well I'm gonna hold you to
that standard and by that standard this
thing falls woefully short your kids
will love it but if you're like me and
you love the original for its depth and
how well thought-out its thematic
strengths were you will find this one
sorely lacking in anything other than
the most superficial elements of visuals
and humor and song which are all strong
but for me not enough so I really hope I
really really hope that Disney can be
done with sequels for a while to their
animated films they seem to be like
there's no sequels on the docket for a
while and also I want to stress sequels
don't always have to be things
completely falling apart
I was shocked how much I liked toys
for and lego movie too just to use
examples from earlier this year but this
wreck-it Ralph to just no no Disney give
it a rest okay
because especially with with the with
films that everything came together as
well as it did yeah it's just it it was
a bit of a frustrating experience for me
so that's frozen - you seen it would you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
because there's buttons and links the
merch which I mentioned at the top of
the whole thing all of that check it out
help me out patreon etc etc or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]